Hi, I'm Max Kuhn.
I'm a statistician, and work as
a Software Engineer at RStudio.
I mostly focus on open source
tools for building models.
I run the tidymodels
group, and tidymodels
the collection of
R packages that
have very similar
syntax and design
principles in the Tidyverse.
So we've made a
lot of improvements
to Tidymodels in the
less six months.
Some of those improvements have
been around user interfaces,
so we have better ways of
specifying which predictors
are added to our model.
We've made other
improvements around
computational efficiency.
So we have limited support
now for sparse matrices
and expanded support
for parallel processing.
Now I like to talk about more
in this video a specific package
that we just released
called finetune.
And finetune is an expansion
of our tune package,
and gives two additional ways
to optimize hyperparameters
or tuning parameters of models.
Now those are
types of parameters
that can't be directly
estimated from the data,
such as the number of
neighbors in the k-nearest
neighbor model.
And so one variation we'll
look at in this presentation
is a new method of
doing grid search,
and the other method is
another iterative method
called simulated anneal.
To illustrate the methods
that we'll talk about today,
we use a cell segmentation data
from the modeldata package.
It's a two-class
classification problem
with about 58
numeric predictors.
We use a support
vector machine.
And for the support
vector machine,
there's a variety of tuning
parameters, such as the cost
value or the radial
basis function kernel
parameter called sigma.
And then this talk will be
about two different ways
of finding optimal
parameters of these values.
Now these tuning parameter
values are important.
They have a big influence on
the model fit in performance.
The problem is we can't directly
estimate them from the data,
so we need to find
good ways of coming up
with values for
those two parameters,
even though we can't
directly estimate them.
To measure performance, we'll
use 10-fold cross-validation,
and we'll measure the
area under the ROC curve.
Now, the model definitions
and the complete code
set that you can use to
reproduce these analyzes are
shown at the link here.
So to give some
visual demonstration
of what we're
trying to do, what I
did is it took these two
different tuning parameters.
And generate a very large
grid, and resampled them.
And that gives a sense of what
the truly best result would
be from our search.
And you can see here on the left
hand side, this contour plot,
blue values indicate poor
performance of the ROC curve,
and then white values
are more optimal.
And so you can see the lower
diagonal of the search space
is pretty flat
and not very good.
And as you go to
the upper diagonal,
there's sort of like a
little mountainous ridge that
has good performance values.
And the best performance value
on the left hand side plot
as shown by the black dot.
And any, really, point
along the ridge that goes in
that black dot were down
towards the Southeast,
we give a pretty
good performance.
The problem is if we
go over that ridge,
that dark spot there which you
can see a little bit better
on the right hand
side surface plot
gives really, really
poor performance.
So we want to find the values
of these tuning parameters,
and we'll be trying to find the
best ones which are indicated
in the white on the plots.
Now the first method
we'll talk about
is something called
racing methods,
and this is sort of an
alteration of grid search
that's been around
for quite a while.
Now in ordinary grid
search, what you would do
is come up with a candidate
set of parameter values
that you want to try.
And then you'd measure
their performance usually
using resampling, and then pick
the one that seems to be best
or gives you has the
characteristics that you like.
Now the problem with
this is you have
to evaluate a potentially
large number of models
to get performance estimates
until you can make a decision.
So let's say we do 20
values of the support vector
machine tuning
parameters, and then we
use 10-fold
cross-validation, that would
be about 200 total model fits.
And we can't make
a decision on which
tuning parameters are good or
bad until we do all that work.
So what racing methods do
is they sort of incrementally
evaluate the resamples.
So in the first
couple of resamples,
you proceed as normal, and
measure their performance.
And then what you
do subsequently
is do an interim analysis
after each resample
to figure out
basically-- are there
tuning parameters have a
low probability of being
called the best results.
And so one way we
could do that as we
could fit in an ANOVA
model to those results
where the outcome is, let's
say, the area under the ROC
curve, or whatever performance
metric you want to use.
And the predictive
factor is the qualitative
tuning parameter combinations,
like in a model 1,
model 12, and so on.
So what we can do is we
can evaluate those, and see
which ones are statistically
different from the best
possible.
And if they are, we
can discard them.
Now, there's another--
there's a variety
of ways to do racing methods.
We have a second one
implemented in finetune
that uses win-loss statistics
and something called
the Bradley-Terry model,
and treats these data
as if they were
sports competition.
And if you want to learn
more about these methods
and particularly how we
implemented them here,
there's a paper there from
2014 that has the details.
And for our particular
example, we'll
use a grid of 20 support vector
machine candidate values that
are generally with
space-filling design,
and we'll show how
racing can be used
to efficiently evaluate them
compared to ordinary grid
search.
So let's illustrate the race.
So let's say we
take our 10-folds,
and we randomly arrange them.
So they're in a random order.
You take the first fold,
and do what we normally do.
We'd compute our models,
and then make predictions,
and measure let's say the
area under the ROC curve.
Now in the plot which
you see is on the y-axis
is just the model
number, which you just
sort of arbitrarily number.
There's 20 of them.
Now on the x-axis, we see
the measure of performance.
And so the blue
dot from model 12
indicates that it had the
best performance across all
the tuning parameter values.
And then the rest of the points
show the loss of performance
compared to the current best.
So you can see model
12 is the current best,
but model 17 was close behind.
And on the bottom
there, model 16
did not have very
good performance.
And so this is after we've
evaluated the first resample.
Now in the second resample,
we do the same thing.
We just resample and compute
the performance metrics
for all 20 tuning
parameter values.
Now in this plot instead of
the individual ROC values,
these points
represent the average
of two ROC area under the
curve values for each model.
Now perform--the leader switch
from model 12 to model 17,
but you can still
see that there's
a variety of
different models that
do not have very good
performance compared to those.
Now iteration 3, we start
doing the interim analysis.
In this case, we're
going to be talking
about the ANOVA method.
And what that allows us to do
is put a confidence interval
on the loss of
performance compared
to the leader for each
tuning parameter value.
And so you can see the
ones that are in black,
there's no evidence
to reject that they're
statistically different
from the best value in blue.
But the ones in gray
that you can see
are statistically
different from that,
and therefore, we think it
would be pretty good idea
to discard them from
further consideration.
So basically, we use
the ANOVA statistics
to figure out which
tuning parameter
values to keep resampling, and
which ones we can get rid of.
In this particular case
in the third iteration,
we're getting rid of 17
different tuning parameter
values.
Now iteration 4, the
confidence intervals
tighten up, pretty
considerably, and model 1
there falls out to where
we're left with two models.
And as we keep
resampling, you can
see that we're getting
closer and closer
to having one fall out.
And then interation
9 of 10, model 12
finally is discarded, because
it's not statistically--
or because it is statistically
different than the best.
So this is on the 9th fold
out of 10. What we normally
do is if we have any situation
where there's only one left
over, we keep resampling it
til it has the full precision
that we would like to
measure performance.
So after 9 iterations,
basically, we
filter out all but 1
tuning value combination.
And then we just
resample model 17 once.
And what the result
is instead of fitting
the full set of 200
model fits, we actually
considered 74 model fits.
So it's a pretty substantial
reduction in both time
and evaluations of models.
And since our inner analysis
method is not very slow,
we're able to call these
values pretty quickly.
And so the nice
thing about racing
is you can do a very
large grid if you like,
and do it pretty efficiently.
Because chances
are, you will not
be resampling the full grid for
all of the possible resamples.
The code for racing
is shown here.
It's very similar to the tune_grid
function in the tune package.
And you can see that
we first set the seed,
so we make sure we get
reproducible results.
And then what we do is run
the tune_race_anova function,
its arguments are very,
very similar to tune_grid.
The relevant one that's shown
here is the grid argument,
and that could either be an
integer that says, basically
how many tuning parameter
combinations you
want to evaluate,
and let the function
figure out which to do.
Or you could pass
in a data frame
there that has the exact
combinations that you're
interested in.
There's a control
argument that lets
you specify a lot of the
numerical aspects of things
like, the size of the
confidence interval that you
use for elimination and so on.
There's also a
verbose_elim option
that does some logging
that shows you the progress
as you proceed.
You can see there it
shows that we eliminated
17 tuning parameter values in
the first iteration and so on.
Now if you'd like to try the
other racing method that's
based on win-loss
statistics, that function
is called tune_race_win_loss.
And the syntax is
identical to what
we see here in tune_race_anova.
So as I mentioned, racing is
really a grid search method
that's done very efficiently.
And again in grid search,
you predefine all the values
you want to look at.
So the next method
we'll talk about
is an iterative search method
based on simulated annealing
where new values are determined
after each current value.
So you don't predefine
the tuning parameter values.
So simulated annealing is really a
pretty old search routine,
and it conducts a biased
random walk around
our tuning parameter space.
And the bias comes in because
once it creates a new tuning
parameter candidate
and evaluates it,
it may discard that
from the search.
And pretend like
it never existed.
Or if the results are not too
far from optimal or a new best,
it would accept that,
and proceed from there.
So we'll show that in
detail in a little bit
as we show the example.
One thing we should
talk about is
how simulating comes up with
its next value to evaluate.
So on the right hand
side, we sort of
have a plot where the black
line shows a search that's
gone through 6 iterations,
and is slowly going down
towards the bottom right.
And then, once we are
at that last point,
we need to generate values that
are within a local neighborhood
of the current best.
So what simulated annealing
would do is find values
that are not too different
from the one
you're currently evaluating.
So what we've done
is we've generated
a variety of random
combinations, that
are shown in red there, that
are within some sort of radius
around the current best.
And then, we would select one
from random as the next point
that we should evaluate.
Now the biased random
walk part comes in
because, if we select one
of those and the performance
is not as good as the current
value, we have two choices.
The other algorithm can
either accept it, and proceed
from it going forward.
Or discard it, and again pretend
as if it was never generated.
In the determining factors for
whether we discard or accept
a result are based
on two things. One
is how early you are
in the search process.
So you're much more likely
to accept suboptimal values
at the early parts of
the search progress.
That's how simulated
annealing works.
And as you get to
the later iterations,
you're much less likely
to accept poor values.
Now the second factor
in that decision
is how bad was the
current result.
So if the current result
is just slightly worse
than the current
best, it's more likely
that you would accept it.
But if it's a
really awful point,
probabilistically,
it's less likely
that you would consider
that is the current point,
and base your next
point off of that one.
So we'll show this
in some detail
with our current example.
So here's our search space
that we looked at earlier.
I've generated a grid of four
different tuning parameter
values, and evaluated
them using resampling.
The current best from that
grid is the green dot.
Simulated annealing will
start from that green dot,
and proceed from there.
So on the first
iteration, we're going
to define again
this neighborhood
around that green dot, and
randomly generate a point.
And so when we did that, it actually
turns out it's a new best.
It's going towards
the better results.
And so we keep that, and then
base the iteration 2 results
on this value.
Now in iteration 2, we go
in kind of a poor direction,
and get actually
fairly bad results.
And they're low enough to
where we would discard this
as being suboptimal.
And so we go to
iteration 3, it's
based on results
from iteration 1
as you'll see in just a second.
So discarding it
means, we do not
use it to generate the
next point in the search.
So in iteration 3, you see
we get another new best,
and then we can keep
going around the search
by finding things in
our local neighborhood.
Now, one of the things
about simulating annealing
is it's a global
search method, which
means it can go back, and
reevaluate areas that it
might have already evaluated.
And so in this particular
result on interation 8,
it goes back in a
different direction.
And we accepted a suboptimal.
As you can see, we're going
to go into an area that's
not very good, and we're getting
a series of just poor results.
Now simulated annealing
also has this feature
where you can do a restart.
So if you don't have good
results within a certain number
of iterations, you
can trigger the search
to start from its
last known best point
and proceed from there.
And that is actually
what happens here.
But we still have another
suboptimal result,
and then we start to search
again from the current best.
And so we proceed along here.
It happens again.
We go off in a bad direction
and then we restart.
And so you can see, we're close
to a number of iterations,
so I did 30 iterations here.
And it would just
continue to look until it
finds better and better values.
So that's a little
graphical representation
of how simulated
annealing works.
If you want to use
this in code, the code
is very similar
to the tune based
function in the tune package.
The arguments are
almost all the same.
You could tell a number of
iterations to proceed from.
Again, there's another
control parameter
that determines things like
the size of local neighborhood
and so on, so it has some
of the numerical properties
that you can tweak for
simulated annealing.
And it also has a verbose method.
So if you set that to true,
you get some nice logging
as the search continues.
What's nice about this is if
you're running interactively,
and it's been
running for a while,
and you feel like maybe it's
done as best as it could do,
you can manually
interrupt the execution
of the tune_sim_anneal function,
and it will return
all the results
that it's achieved so far.
So by manually
interrupting it, you
don't lose all the results
that you've generated.
It will give you the ones
that you've completed to date.
And so that's the
other function that we
wanted to show for model
tuning in the finetune package.
If you want to learn more, look
at tidymodels.org especially
if you're new to Tidymodels.
It has a lot of articles
on getting started,
a nice sequence of examples
of how to use recipes,
and parsnip, and a variety
of different things.
There's other articles
there for people
who have used it where
in more advanced articles
that show different
aspects of Tidymodels.
Julia Silge and I are also
writing a book on tidymodels.
It's about halfway done
at the end of 2020.
Chapter 13 is about
grid search, and it
has more details about racing.
And Chapter 14 is
about iterative search,
and one of the
things it describes
there is simulated annealing.
You can also look at the
finetune webpage, which
has a nice formatted reference
section, as well as a blog post
that we used to
launch the package.
Thanks for watching,
and I hope you enjoy it.